[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo américa
de france24 jorge hurtado ya está
conmigo en el estudio jorge pues vamos a
analizar hablando del precio del gas y
la electricidad en europa que también lo
vamos desarrollando toda esta semana así
es bueno estos precios cayeron
justamente hoy tras unas declaraciones
del presidente ruso vladimir putin
putin aseguró que podría empezar a
bombear gas a los almacenes europeos a
la brevedad varios funcionarios europeos
sospechaban que rusia había estado
limitando el suministro para presionar a
europa con la aprobación de su
controvertido gasoducto nord swing 2s
gaseoducto raúl construido en el malba
artístico mide unos 1.200 kilómetros y
su construcción duró al menos 5 años con
un costo de 11 mil millones de dólares
cuando se ha probado duplicaría las
exportaciones de gas desde moscú a
alemania sin tener que pasar por ucrania
sea un fuente de bloomberg a rusia
también le preocupa que la subida de
precios pueda destruir la demanda los
precios del gas natural en europa se han
aumentado en un año casi 500 por ciento
rusia prometió beber gas natural a los
almacenes europeos una vez que termine
de llenar su propia reserva algo que
podría ocurrir el 8 de noviembre la
noticia raúl hizo que el precio holandés
del gas en noviembre cayera
6,75 euros hasta los setenta y 7,75
euros por el megavatio/hora el precio
del gas británico también disminuyó de
que me quería decir ahora si ya
interrumpía pero hablemos ahora de las
cifras de la inflación en españa ha sido
bueno allí los precios continuaron al
alza afectados también que está
afectando los precios de la electricidad
y la inflación se ubicó en 5.5 por
ciento anual en octubre la mayor cifra
desde septiembre de 1992 según publicó
el instituto nacional de estadística de
los precios de la energía se han visto
afectados por el encarecimiento de las
materias primas que inciden en la tarifa
energética que pagan hogares y empresas
españolas analistas esperaban una subida
general del 48 por ciento de septiembre
la inflación se ubicó en 4 por ciento y
ahora pues alcanzó el 5,5 el precio de
la energía ha crecido raúl de forma
exponencial españa por ejemplo hoy el
megavatio/hora en el mercado mayorista
vale 205 euros eso es casi cinco veces
más que el mismo día de octubre del año
anterior este incremento de la inflación
sucede por el llamado efecto base que es
cuando los precios de hoy se comparan
con lo que hace un año pero hay que
tomar en cuenta que en octubre 2020 la
inflación cayó afectada por la crisis
del cobi pero ahora la recuperación
económica mundial está generando el
efecto compuesto expertos alertan de la
influencia negativa que puede tener el
aumento del precio de la energía en el
crecimiento económico previsto para este
año que el gobierno español situó en 65
por ciento por gente en nuestro
continente en cuba las autoridades
brindaron sus datos económicos que
revelaron bueno está estos datos no son
nada alentadores para la isla y sobre
todo luego del impacto que tuvo allí en
la economía la pandemia del coronavirus
ahí la economía perdió el 13 por ciento
su producto interno bruto entre 2020 y
septiembre de 2021 las autoridades
monetarias de ese país revelaron que los
ingresos en divisas se cuantifican en
septiembre en 2000 millones de dólares
recordaron que en 2020 el país dejó de
recibir 2.400 millones de dólares el
titular de economía y planificación
alejandro hill aseguró que las
exportaciones representaron unos 1.300
millones de dólares mientras que las
importaciones rondan los 5 mil 800
millones escuchemos que dijo el titular
de economía de cuba
el endurecimiento bloqueó la pandemia
nos han impuesto a condiciones
excepcionales
en dos años hemos perdido más de 13%
protesten los muchos de los problemas
dependen de nosotros mismos de que
trabajemos mejor eso es cierto pero en
la concretera también hacen falta
recursos hay que destacar que los
indicadores económicos de cuba provienen
del estado cubano no se auditan en el
exterior y son difíciles de contrastar
ya que el país no forma parte de
organismos como el fondo monetario
internacional o el banco mundial jorge
ahora sí hablemos de los indicadores
económicos mundiales
bueno arrancamos en asia el hang seng
cerró hoy con pérdidas por los malos
resultados de las petroleras y
aseguradoras en el tercer trimestre y en
europa las acciones operan mixtas antes
de la actualización de la política del
banco central europeo mientras que
alguno de los principales fabricantes de
automóviles advierten de problemas en la
producción por la famosa escasez de
chips siempre al día que no tiene para
hoy bueno hablamos del mercado laboral
español que es humo 359.300 ocupados en
el tercer trimestre de este año frente
al trimestre anterior con lo que supera
la barrera 20 millones de puestos
ocupados un nivel que no se registraba
desde finales de 2008
jorge gracias por todos estos datos
económicos nos vemos más adelante en un
segundo bloque de economía aquí en
directo américa ahora vamos a ver
nuestro reportaje del día le parece
vamos a ver vamos a ver
[Música]